and we start with a story we have been
following now since sunday night
bail has now been set for a local mother
involved in a high-speed crash that
killed her one-year-old son
our bianca holman has more now from the
courthouse
a judge set bail for 50 thousand dollars
along with alcohol and electronic
monitoring for lauren precia
the 24 year old appeared in court for
her arrest on sunday
the arrest report shows she was driving
at 121 miles per hour in a 45 mile zone
at the time of the collision near lake
mead in rampart
her son royce jones was killed in the
crash close friends of the
one-year-old's father cameron
hubbard-jones told 8 news now
both he and priscilla were on the phone
with each other while driving
they were headed home for a custody
exchange they say he tried to stop her
from speeding while
driving with their baby the fact that
you would do that with your infant child
in the car gives this court very grave
concerns
as to the safety of the community
because the rest of the public is not
immediately related to you by blood
and if you would do this with an infant
in the car that causes the court
concerns regarding public safety
precia faces multiple charges including
dui resulting in death
felony reckless driving and abuse
neglect or endangerment of a child
the las vegas native is due back in
court on july 20.
reporting from downtown bianca holman 8
news now